le président russe a commencé par rendre
hommage au personnel soignant qui se
trouve je cite sur la première ligne
dans le combat contre le coronavirus
elle a bien entendu souligné que toutes
les ressources de l'état a été mise en
oeuvre pour gérer pour contenir cette
crise sanitaire les crises sanitaires
qui a d'ores et déjà une conséquence
très concrète à savoir le report de la
grande consultation populaire voulue par
vladimir poutine concernant la réforme
constitutionnelle
la priorité absolue pour nous c'est la
santé la vie et la sécurité de la
population
pour cette raison il me semble important
de reporter ce scrutin à plus tard
nous allons évaluer l'évolution de la
situation sur son plan et sur la base de
l'avis des scientifiques des médecins et
spécialistes
nous prendrons une décision sur le
report de cette date de ce scrutin
avec toujours en tête le maintien de la
population à la maison afin d'éviter la
propagation du coronavirus vladimir
poutine a également invité tous les
salariés à rester chez eux la semaine
prochaine il est important ici de faire
tout pour limiter une propagation rapide
de l'épidémie et par conséquent je
déclare la semaine qui vient comme une
semaine de congé avec maintien des
salaires c'est à dire qu'à partir du
samedi 28 mars jusqu'au dimanche 5 avril
l'ensemble des structures vont être en
congés qu'il s'agisse des services de
santé des transports des banques et des
services de l'état
ces secteurs-là maintiendront leurs
activités normales
mais cette semaine de congé a pour
objectif justement de limiter une
propagation de l'épidémie et je
m'adresse à tous les citoyens du pays
afin de réduire l'impact de cette crise
sanitaire sur l'économie russe vladimir
poutine a également annoncé tout un
train de nouvelles mesures à savoir le
maintien du versement des différentes
allocations sociales et ce sans même
voir présenter de nouveaux justificatifs
le report des remboursements de prêts ou
alors encore le soutien aux petites et
moyennes entreprises sous la forme de
reports de cotisations ou encore de
versements d'impôts l'objectif des
autorités est clair est à la fois
délicat éviter au maximum la propagation
du cornât virus tout en essayant
d'épargner l'économie russe